now I want to read you a story alright
so let me give you a little background
to this story this story popped into my
head in one chunk like complete which I
thought was kind of interesting but it
was also a story that emerged in
solution to a problem I had been
thinking about for a long time because I
was dealing with this guy who didn't
want to grow up so he's caught in a kind
of Peter Pan situation and Peter Pan pan
means everything a pan like pantheistic
a Peter Pan is a child who won't grow up
though he's magical well ok fine
children live in a magical world right
they're rife with possibility he's
magical he doesn't want to grow up so he
lives in Neverland with the Lost Boys
Neverland doesn't really exist and the
Lost Boys are obviously boys who haven't
managed to establish some mode of being
and he's in constant battle with Captain
Hook and Captain Hook's a tyrant right a
pirate a negative manifestation of the
negative archetype of social order and
Captain Hook is always fighting Peter
Pan because Peter Pan represents
childhood and vulnerability and he
doesn't want to be vulnerable so they're
locked in this sort of eternal battle
and lots of people I think more commonly
men but not necessarily get caught it in
this Peter Pan problem so I was dealing
with person who was caught in this
situation didn't want to grow up
wouldn't sacrifice childhood and so this
story popped into my head
it's called cockadoodledoo once upon a
time there was a man who had a long hard
journey ahead of him he was trudging
along the way over boulders and through
brushes when he saw a little shiny gnome
with big white teeth in the block toupee
sitting by the side of the road he was
drumming on a log with two white bones
and humming oddly to himself the little
gnome said John why worked so hard why
walk so fast
who knows if you'll ever get there
anyway come over here I have something
to show you
so John walked off the road he was sick
of walking anyway because people kept
throwing sticks and stones at him
little gnome said I have a shiny red
jewel that I would like to sell you
cheap here it is and from beneath his
cloak he pulled the biggest Ruby that
the man had ever seen he must have
weighed a hundred pounds and it's Shaun
like the Sun the gnome said do you like
it it's an enchanted stone what will you
offer me for it
and the man said I don't have much much
money but I'll give you everything I
have the gnome looked displeased so Jon
added I could pay some more monthly so
the gnome accepted fair enough buy now
pay later sounds good for me I'm all for
the installment plan so the man gave the
gnome all his money and promised to pay
the rest later and the gnome walked back
into the bush by the road clocking his
teeth and giggling and twitching the
more the man thought about this Ruby
then the great deal he got the happier
he became he started back on the road
with a light heart but soon discovered
that he couldn't make much progress
because 100 pounds was a lot to carry he
said to himself why he continued anyways
I have what I want I'll just stand here
holding my Ruby and when people walk by
they could see how well I've already
done so he stopped a little while one of
his little while later one of his
friends came along so I'm standing there
his friend said John why don't you come
along with me I've just opened a new
business and I could really use some
help come along quick they will be
opening soon John thought that sounded
good but his friend was in a hurry
besides couldn't he see the Ruby how
could he speed along beside him where
would he put his jewel so he said thanks
but I have to take care of my jewel
maybe I'll see you later
his fan looked at him like he was crazy
but he was trying to get somewhere quick
so he just shrugged a bit and said okay
John see you later
then he sped on down the road a little
while later another friend came by and
he said John nice to see you I'm going
back to school there are lots of
wonderful things to learn great things
to do the world is full of unsolved
problems I could use some company
would you like to come along John
thought that sounded pretty good but
this friend too looked like he was in a
hurry
besides standing beside the road holding
the jewel was tiring and he needed all
the energy he had for that so he said to
his friend thanks but I have to take
care of my jewel isn't it beautiful
maybe I'll see you later his friend
looked at him like he was crazy but he
was trying to get somewhere quick so he
just shrugged and said hope everything
goes all right with you see you later
many friends came and went and the years
went by the jewel got heavier and
heavier but the man got more and more
attached to it the only thing was nobody
seemed to notice how beautiful it was
people would rush by and talk about
their plans and nobody had a ruby as big
and nobody seemed likely to get a ruby
as big and you think that someone might
have had said something like at least
nice Ruby John sure wish I had one like
that but it never happened
then one day someone new came down the
road he was bent over and he was thin
and his hair was gray although he didn't
look that all he was carrying a big
dirty rock carefully in his arms and he
wasn't making much progress the strange
figure approached and glanced up at John
then he grinned and said why are you
standing there so stupidly with a big
ugly Rock and your tired old hands you
look pretty daft I bet you wish you had
a big Ruby like the one I am carrying
and John thought his poor man is deluded
he's carrying a rock it is all you have
the Ruby so he said excuse me sir but
you were sadly mistaken I'm the one with
the jewel I met a little-known by the
side of the road and he sold it to me
I'm still paying for it
although not so very much you are
carrying a rock the tired stranger
looked annoyed he said I don't know what
game you're playing mister you have a
rock I have a jewel the little gnome you
described sold it to me and he said it
was the only one I've been carrying it
for 20 years and I'll never let it go
and John said but I've been carrying
mine for 20 years - it can't be just a
rock rock or jewel on and on they argued
suddenly out step the little gnome as if
he had never left
only this time he wasn't so little he
was bigger and redder and menacing and
his laugh sounded like the rattling of
chains quit arguing you two I've never
seen a sight quite
so pathetic you're carrying rocks both
of you and if you would have ever had
the sense to put them down for a second
or two you would have seen that oh well
at least you were diligent I played a
mean trick
I feel bad so I'm gonna give you what
you really deserve do you want what you
really deserve and John and the thin
stranger nodded eagerly finally they
thought you haven't seen anything yet
throw down your rocks so John and the
thin stranger obeyed each rock split
down the middle when it hit the ground
out flowed a river of ravenous white
worms which rushed towards the men and
devoured them whole while they thrashed
about and screamed soon nothing was left
except a leg bone from each the little
gnome picked them up and walked off the
road he sat down by a hollow log and
started to drum he drummed Denny waited
and he hummed an odd little tune a
picture of food feeds the whole hungry
clan the image of good makes the whole
healthy man why walk for miles why do
the work just smile the smile success
after all is a quirk life isn't real
that's the message I give it's easy that
way plus who wants to live
so needless to say the guy that I was
telling this story to you never listened
to it and things really didn't go well
for him for a long long time and they
really didn't go well for him until he
was willing to give up some of the
things he was carrying along so he had
acquired for example a number of things
that he couldn't afford and the fact
that he was carrying them right paying
for the month after month meant he
couldn't afford to get an education
it was perfectly willing to sacrifice
the possibility of getting an education
for the image of success rather than the
reverse right and he was completely
irritated at the world because he had
all these trappings of success which no
what he admired also admired and he
absolutely wasn't getting anywhere and
he thought that was tremendously unfair
but the truth of the matter was that had
he put down what he was carrying for
even a moment then he would have been
able to get to where he wanted to go and
that's a motif that succinctly and
dramatically describes the necessity for
sacrifice
[Music]